addio
ciao persone ciao gente bella addio
massima in live non lo so perché ogni
volta mi piace questo dubbio porca vacca
che non siamo in live o meno ciao bel
belli come state tutto a posto madonna
che caldo fa rega io mi metto a farle
live fine luglio inizio agosto
cazzo di genio sono mai così family
friendly ciao persone perché sono giallo
che questa luce che cazzo di problemi
asta luce perché sono giallo poète sono
già sono un simpson non so per non è
vero in realtà cioè più o meno sono
giallo non c'è un motivo preciso prove
tutto bene ragazzi oh che bello che mi è
rimasta la schiuma da barba mentre sto
facendo la live sì perché io ogni tanto
mi faccio la barba è solo per sembrare
più grande non perché vi serva persone
tutto bene porca vacca come son carico
mi chiede questo di un fresco che non
avete idea o hanno saputo fare il bagno
giusto per per l'occasione allora
ragazzuoli oggi e domenica
oggi e domenica quindi che cosa volete
che giochiamo
la risposta è che visse bene la risposta
è sbagliata perché più di sei una merda
però facciamo così proviamo a fare un
paio di place
proprio così alla veloce giusto per
scaldarci un attimo così arriva un bel
po di gente e poi giochiamo a venerdì 13
visto che tutti quanti mi state
chiedendo in massa di giocare venerdì 13
direi che possiamo giocare bene di 13
oggi solo che non so parlare e scrivere
nello stesso momento scusatemi cioè
questo handicap grosso
l'unica roba è che i ragazzi io faccio
veramente cagare a spruzzo su venerdì 13
quindi spero che perché vi vada bene lo
stesso anche perché non
non sono proprio capace dice non so
capace qua porca di una eva schifosa
laida figura di serie b 13 del suo
capaci porca eva cosa ci guardò
e me lo popolano già tutti in partenza
però questo è un altro discorso si sente
si vede bene da posto ecco sisti seconds
non lo posso fare ragazzi perché tra
poco esce un video su assist di second
che ho registrato già che non vi spoiler
niente ma vi dico solo che potrei aver
vinto però non è uno spoiler è però
forse ci potete arrivare da solo fatto
lo stesso di prima un [ __ ] genio non
c'è proprio questo gioco ci siamo l'anti
cristo insieme con una roba che odio
30.000 spettatori a 35.000 inizio
venerdì 13 ragazzi a 36.000 magari kg
john che il calendario è poi quello è un
altro discorso
si vede bene si sente bene a posto ma
perché non mi ha dato tanto lì nei tuoi
commenti
totalmente sono due miliardi e mezzo
come cazzo di leggo anche ci fosse il
problema che si stesse vedendo un porno
non potrei capirlo perché
però nel dubbio occupare lo nel dubbio
mi fa sentire bene stato oggi non è mai
servito un cazzo ecco le ragazze però
tomi c
come fai a chiamarti tommy sci che
problemi ci non morite dove guardano in
teoria quello che sarebbe non è quello
l'obiettivo per presente grazie tomi c
[Musica]
cosa cazzo è successo cosa cosa cazzo
come cosa o come ma non ero vivo bene la
vita
va bene va bene siamo a 30 mila dai 35
per venerdì 13 vi prego fatemi finire
questa agonia di f così giochiamo un po
a giochi fatti bene è sporca e va in
profondità
porca vacca diacono volevano farsi belli
ma donne tendono a salire in gesù ma poi
mi gasa di pro e spero che non vada il
registro è più di spaccio un miliardo di
tagli perché prima di riuscirci che ci
mette una vita oggi per ci va bene senza
bene se non so perché ma ci sono allego
dopo vado ecco gioca venerdì 13 e di
pupi la farà sì magari le impostazioni
le notifiche disabilitiamo la non si
vedono propri degli altri benson
riuscendo a far tutto 31.000 raga non
bastano io 35.000 iniziamo averne tre se
non iniziamo un cazzo i post dai film
fatti fini e stagioni sa che prima o poi
faccio una figura di merda su fx quindi
fatelo a finire il premio tipo questa è
una figura di merda però sono morto
stasera alla fine le mani dietro
simpatico questo gioco
[Musica]
ah sì ok fa niente passi con cento per
cento però a tutti ce li ho fatti che
italiano è per ora tutti ce li ho fatti
era che fa caldo anche per me scusate mi
abbiate pazienza poi faccio lo youtube e
romney che sono studiato tantissimo
33mila non basterà che ancora tra ancora
duemila persone voglio voglio lo stadio
di san siro e poi iniziamo a venerdì 3
[Musica]
porca vacca la tua madre in vaticano ma
perché non riesco a far secco ma perché
non c'è le braccia madonna che sono
forte io che so versetti cadenti a posto
le tracce dal frate impegnati dios
factor ce l'ho fatta a farli giunti per
io comunque ve lo voglio dire sto gioco
sta diventando veramente strano negli
ultimi tempi è veramente strano vero
andrea tolfa che non ci servono su
facebook solo perché ho una dignità a
caso non attrae per cento vai così
ragano fanno infatti dire che ho fatto
più livelli in cinque minuti che in
tutta la mia vita su fb ma che roba
ho mai impossible poi è che mi che è
impossibile bardi come cazzo possibile
un fenomeno odio saranno gli spettatori
in live sarà termine sarà che è evidente
la forza mi diede la forza e medie
giusta forza porca vacca mica
incredibile non so perché ho giusto dire
guarda ci assurdo cioè quella veramente
rai e mi verrebbe da continuarla anche
se vi fa cagare che visse solo perché
sto vincendo tutti i livelli ci
incredibile questo gioco io ho già fatto
tutti gli amici definiti non so il
possible rock da in ultim'ora ga poi dai
dai dai paula ricavata devo farcela
almeno questo
almeno questo zio dai cazzo e va bene
così trentacinquemila e direi che
possiamo finirla qua volete venerdì 13
signori che poi miglia rega incredibile
che sto gioco ancora vada dopo la punta
che ho iniziato cinque anni fa porco
schifo ancora va va bene non facciamo
domande 35.000 in live bassano ragazzi e
le promesse sono promesse inception
perché romica stanno arrivando sempre
fisso è bene a parte fare il salto
anthony con 40 europa c'è minchia raga
40.000 spettatori creiamo un portale per
l'altro mondo cioè non so vabbè basta
ecco distragga per oggi ho dato già
basta ho già fatto più livelli di quadri
e faccio di solito non mi sono neanche
impegnato non lo so e vabbè allora
minchia sono veramente negato anche per
venerdì 13 però se lo volete tutti poi
me ne faccio un player a non battere
andai non cagato un cazzo fatemi giocare
anche le cose fatte serie però andiamo
anche su merito e si vede sì dai ti
prego gioco cammi s sport così dico ogni
volta che parte sto schifo dintroni di
un infarto
no perché nelle registrazioni non si
vede raga perché va quarto che giace dal
menu ma mica ogni volta che parte stanno
già dentro mica go addosso non sono
neanche iniziato quickplay madonna checa
garagano che caga 40.000 live va bene
ragazzette abbastanza bene i carri one
sono maria sono martino gallitto sono
martino garruzzo nel dubbio mi sono
chiamato così per camuffarmi ciò anche
l'avatar di martino garanza eccolo qua
numerico non miliardi di richieste su
steam anche se ciò rivela la lista piena
ragazzo alisa pieno non mi intasate le
richieste l'amicizia porca eva a raga io
non so se abbiate pazienza se faccio
pagare a questo gioco non è colpa mia io
mi ci metto di buona volontà e che
faccio schifo e il problema è quello non
lo so poi però magari o magari linko in
questa non ce la tiriamo però sono
contento che mi piace avere editrice
anche perché un gioco fatto bene tranne
il fatto non si vince mai è un gioco
fatto bene si vincesse anche sarebbe top
tutto a posto raga se arriviamo a 40
mila faccio dalla live nudo milano i
pantaloni ve lo prometto
ve lo prometto che ne li leggo qui non
sono anche perché premi mi gasa sapere
di giocare davanti a tante persone
proprio perché a fare le figure di merda
non le vede nessuno e prodotto almeno
così ci siamo
l'aifa 3d porca vacca quanto tempo sei
bravissimo grazie non l'ha fatto un
cazzo ancora sopravvisse al nel menu
sono bravissimo colosso fare sempre
saputo fare meno meno sono brava
applicare i tasti tipo pronto ci vuole
skill mi da anni per imparare sarò però
kevin folk apparsi non ok
meno male che non mi ha messo uno di voi
caricamenti che è mica sono family
friendly al top a porcaccia vacca dai ti
prego gioco fa mi essere jason fammi
essere jason almeno in live
ti prego la marca se lo prendo a fare
l'unico che riesce a essere jason e
pietro e basta come fa essere jason
colori non riesce nessuno solo lui
quindi incredibile
la speranza è l'ultima a morire prima ci
sono io poi muore e la speranza una
partenza cioè che non dura neanche
cinque minuti però se meccanici raga o
mi dovete accompagnare perché io potete
accompagnare solo perché io mi chiami
caso sempre di brutto ma non mi
mai invece gioco da tre settimane anzi
quasi un mese non ho ancora imparato le
mappe rischio di aborto dai
fin qua figura ormai che cazzo
questa ci spero a fare nel sanchez e non
lo so neanche io a posto allora
ragazzuoli partiamo subito vicino alla
macchina vediamo cosa riusciamo a fare
mancano tanica batterie chiavi prego ai
miei compagni a quegli esseri inutili
chiamati anche compagni di aiutarmi
visto che sono in la chimica non mi
danno ma in attesa è la madonna mi che
anche siamo partiti porca vacca ma stai
calmo miglia questo qua è stronzo subito
forti file allora non riesco a trovare
subito qualcosa di decente tipo chiave
ok perfetto la chiara noti scuse a è
perché merito mi giardi come ricorda lei
comunque io già adottati parlato non ho
mai capito se quando stacca la luce
jason non ho mai capito se la stacca
tutti c'è proprio tutti tutti o solo a
me che sono in questa casa mini non
capito se cielo vicino o altro credo di
no perché a questo la mi avrebbe già
stuprato però finita già finita ha
spiegato la casa di sfortunata nella
vita hanno trovato manco un pezzo di
carta presso fiamm il naso altro che
armi o chiavi o altre romy niente ho
trovato mi chiamo la casa piloti di
questa non esiste comunque deduco che la
luce la tolga a tutti perché se no
guarda c'è qualcun altro c'è pepe
ciao peppe ogni quando smetti di giocare
a calcio che iniziò nardi 13 bene mi fa
piacere o le chiavi la trovate lui io
sento la musica di cesa ma non vedo
bisogna dove cassano eccolo feb e spara
lì c'è la pistola spara gli sbagli pepe
spara lì poi crossa in mezzo nel dubbio
che io calcio sparma perché tra tutti i
punti dove può essere jason proprio da
noi due stronzi che siamo qua da soli
niente cagare il pene non solo a noi
chiavi via bravo che hai trovato le
chiavi almeno uno che fa qualcosa porca
vacca che nessuno con cazzola marco la
mappa è utile
la mappa è utile mica spero che non mi
sbuchi di jason in casa che non so dove
la porta e quella porta perfetto mi
chiama quasi ha sfondato la porta mafia
allora ho neanche visto allora chiarisce
abbiamo quindi devo guardare per la
tanica che non ha trovato quindi
sicuramente non c'è sesto condello più
di quanto tempo per chiude la porta a
chiave ma perché non so chiudere ma per
niente allora riusciamo di qua perché mi
cadde addosso delle taniche batteria
caricabatteria veloci taniche batteria
veloci parte che ho trovato la mappa
quindi dovrei vedere perfetto
ovviamente noi siamo in due quali altri
sono in tre sono tutti su doveva jayson
vado e siamo in due perché siamo stronzi
noi avete niro ha occupato tutti a
tenere occupato finora occupato bravo
zio
sono fortunato che ho trovato dico che
pensano a giocare quindi lo tiene
occupato
no perché ogni tanto torno dei dementi e
non sono fan in campo la batteria al
materiale un regalo la tua batteria
fermi tutti fermi tutti e sua batteria
zitti zitti che stavolta ed è quella
buona non sento come si parla qua qual è
il tasto eccolo find the tanica che io
c'ho alla batteria avrà capito si era
capito sicuramente io ho studiato invece
cinque anni sono uscito
8 meritato tutti tutti tutti studiosi
qua è che mi prende per il culo tutti
studioso allora stavolta non ogni volta
porca vacca chiuso sto coso lo sparo
subito per sbaglio
quello era un orgasmo o qualcuno è morto
non lo so comunque jason se n'è andato
spero di sì perché almeno metto la de
belém come pepe uscito dalla partita
aperta sono la sola spero che se n'è
andato jason speriamo che se ne sia
andato perché se non se ne è andato su
di una tartana visto il corpo per terra
si è cagato addosso mi tocca grado
strutture io allora qua c'è la base ci
sono le chiavi e va bene si masticano
spiegano si gesone da moro ragazze sono
i valori no cazzo c'è una trappola per
terra by liberati liberati via libera tv
latino donna
metti la metti subito la la batteria
subito ok mi chiesta fatte
difficilissima la gara ok ok a cazzo ok
bye bye bye bye bye di un perfetto
perfetto are capitana vai così solo la
tanica ragazzo la tanica
vi prego potevi trovare una cazzo di
tattica vi prego dai mica sarebbe fanta
parte sono mezzo morto vabbè dai mica
poco cosa con come co.co.co cosa guido
col buco del deretano friend finder sta
minchia di tanica guys find the gas
di cosa
everything she modelli sa mai perché
vedo che c'è qualcuno qui so che non
sono io
ok no perché nella mini mappa mi segnava
qualcuno e io sono un mezzo morto perché
sono terrorizzato raga sono mezzo morto
però la tanica qua dove sono io non ci
ho già controllato in tutte le case
purtroppo jason equa quindi se io
riuscissi a trovare una tanica di merda
sei a posto prima che sono mezzo morto
proprio peccato la la roba l'unico
appunto che posso andare questo qua per
vedere però mica ci mette un'ora la
vivace che zoppica porca vacca mi devo
finire col proprio alla gamba video
ferire nipote offrirà una tetta 70 non
mi serve 45.000 in dai raga dopo sta
partita mimì tobio pantaloni ma abbiamo
promesso è una promessa ragazzo ha
promesso fan se siete pervertiti è chi
volete nudo e maledetti dai che ce la
posso fare
dai famiglia serie se riesco a
sopravvivere in live dragamine ma c'è me
ne vado perché porta a cannes ci credo
anche se dubito è un progetto finché da
loro finché da loro posso sperarci mica
si trova la tanica conto godo quanto
godo quanto godo che ho vinto se provata
vi prego dare una tanica fatemi vincere
live minchia che godo con un caimano
perche non la trovo tanti problemi posso
trovare dei medikit nei cassetti che
sarebbe molto utile un medico adesso è
figo razze trova una tanica ci
mancherebbe altro le chiavi sono lì
davanti quindi a posto raga abbiamo solo
più una casa da controllare poi dobbiamo
andare dove c'è jason quindi prego iddio
di trovare una tanica se non una tanica
almeno cosa per curarmi perché sono
ora ga questa è la partita buona ma lo
sento di brutto
quando dico così me la tiro sempre ma
porca vacca questa è quella buona
perché non vedo un cazzo perché son
diventato viola è un potere li jason
questo mi fa di vedere tutto nero
lo schermo con un cazzo non vedo così mi
sparito a quella minima o sono io che
sto morendo
porca vacca cosa fai ora che ho sentito
il rumore che non mi è piaciuto per
niente non so cos'è city steam devo
concentrare mabiglia casse trovo una
schifo di tanica o ma una dai mi chiama
veramente o il tuo contratto 26 casa e
non c'è una tanica del gas
prendete per il culo c'è una donna ma
mai così sfiga porca vacca avevo tutto
c'è incredibile praga incredibile lo
giura ormai ma quanta sfiga possa almeno
recuperare unicamente zio colle col ha
detto sembra un film che fingono ha
detto con le più va beh comunque mi è
tornato lo schermo normale prima non so
perché diventato nero ma sarà il potere
di jason ragan porta ma tutti sono morti
tutti ice skate sono scappati con la
macchina si schifosi
ma [ __ ] allora siete voi che avete
trovato le taniche di mortacci vostri
voglio credere mica sono rimasto
l'ultimo raga da mai
che palle ma perché non sono riuscito a
trovare la tanica in venti case che ho
controllato è bilico solo quest poi
zoppica oppure non possono anche scappa
se mi trova acceso non sono morto perché
non posso scappare il mai nella vita
topico dai mi chiama possibile ora gado
contro a quante case bus a quello
controllare 4 se prima che non 1 mini
uccide prima primo due miglia più veloce
mia nonna che striscia
c'era una sorta di chi a 50.000
spettatori lega stia battendo il record
del canale come cazzo è possibile tutti
volete vedere che me la prendo nel culo
a bene so come aiuto aiuto sballo
aggiunto sparla aiuto ragano no allora
il problema è che non ho non posso
scappare manco volendo perché non
zoppica 1 e secondo non ho trovato manca
la tanica cos'è sta roba
il bagno il bagno eccolo vai vai vai
cura figura figura tiziana quello sta
sfondando ragazzi una tanica vi prego
gesù vi prego datemi una tanica
maledizione quanto tempo i temi che la
trovo almeno qui mica posso sperare di
correre fino alla ma la macchina almeno
una tanica vi prego vi prego vi prego io
vi chiedo tanto solo una tanica
porca di una [ __ ] l'amica maledizione
dai minchia nomi di chi dove e lì è la
madonna del cazzo se il cecchino aia mi
abbia lanciato uno stuzzicadenti aiuta a
distrae distrae distracted sì ma non
funziona o meno funziona ma non funziona
è no è don't a cipro don't ask don't a
cipro touch mihai denuncio hayden yoon c
un fortissimo cazzo ridi lesbica end che
l'unico tudin arzachena capirà cazzo di
dialettica che un micro su di noi ed aic
and bring you my car aveva né scar aiap
aiap lamborghini di lamborghini adiyiah
è adesso pronto il rimorso the girl with
a chance brown ai kings at you to my
lamborghini evidenza mai l'hanno ling
della lamborghini no no des browne des
browne mentiva disi this is not of new
rimorchia girl this is not a visita ai
denuncia è sempre pezzo di merda è però
è bastardo po bastardo lo sei
vabbè
vabbè ho ragazzi sempre sempre così e
noi che io ci ci speri più di tanto
però ogni tanto sarebbe anche carino
trovare tutti i pezzi della macchina
andarsene affanculo sa magari un
vinitaly merci
porca vacca infame è niente ragazzo sta
sfiga incredibile non c'è però mai a
vincere però purtroppo è un peccato
perché porca vacca ci provo sempre mi ci
metto di impegno fortissimo ma non ci
riesco mari e vabbè pazienza comunque
cazzo ridete pure voi porca vacca tutte
lesbiche mai venire di che stava toccare
i colleghi ora gavevo tutto batteria
chiavi mancava solo la schifo di tadic
ha solo la tanica mancava porca di uno
schifoso
mi sarebbe passato che gli altri non
morissero perché
almeno mi ma il milan ci lavorano cuillo
che ero l'unico in giro invece non sono
morti schiantati tutti i due sono
scappati a [ __ ] vabbè conviene
comunque stare in gruppo perché almeno
almeno ci chiamò dicendomi carica 50.000
veramente mi tolgo va bene per minuto
gli arrivi pensi ma di fatto è che non
si vede sono cazzi costruito sta seduto
a giocare però mi son tolti è è gesù vi
prego j successo jason una volta jason
mica sarebbe più bello di una vittoria
giocare i dati siano gli spacco la
faccia tutti almeno mi che a parte che
non saprei giocarci che non ci ho mai
giocato però non sarebbe figo una
possibilità su otto ho fatto tipo 30
partite non non lo sono mai stato jason
non lo sono mai vissuto
1984 dalla lega al mondo con jason
quindi la una chance non mi dice scusi
dove andare ha permesso di soggiorno
dove cazzo le 32 siamo la macchina non
ce l'ho vicino quindi subito fuffa salve
ok dai proviamo ad aggregarsi con lui
allora devo trovare subito subito
batterie tariq ha subito quanto ma
quanto ci fate che la tanica la trovo in
0,3 secondi ma ve lo giuro che la trovo
in questi poco ma sicuro
ma sicuro sempre nei trovarsi dentro due
sempre così mica speriamo che gen sono
almeno non venga da noi che sono la
porca vacca o nasce è già buono ascesa
bonn ci alziamo da essere occhiali
quando sentite questo rumore è perché
sto parlando
questo qua click
anche nei video è così però non tutti
l'hanno capito annotato missino questo
click che si sente so io che parla nella
chat comune la mappa questa no sì che la
mappa a premi la a caso poche belle dame
che bel banchine
la casa è dovuta però se a casa non
c'era un pene ma proprio niente
andiamo nella prossima ma sale quars e
if you find the tanica che la donna ora
come occorre cioè vedi come corre subito
subito bravo claudio subito è partita la
voglia subito di trovarla spiega se
variegato qua dentro di sé uno stronzo
poi perché gesù non puoi preda alle
finestre cos'è questo razzismo si batta
il culo trovato dopo anno che mi segue
perché cioè con capitan i catalani
qahtani che figura che poi mica ci sono
altri modi per scappare ma non
funzionamento quindi sono costretto gli
usa la tanica poi nicchia le trappole le
trappole sono fatte per jason porca
vacca c schiatto sempre io nelle
trappole per terra
ste schifose light per jason sofà temi
che fanno più danni che altro una ma
solo una macchina in sto giro minchia
allora vado subito perché quella di
tanica non c'e nel mezzo da quando
subito la macchina che c'è uno zio solo
ce n'è uno solo lì quindi jason
difficile che vada infatti a cannes
porca vacca schifosa infame faremo che
non mi arrivi dall alto il consumo e
culo
io non ho mai capito se jason vede gli
altri cioè se li vede nella mappa e
quindi sa dove siamo perché mi piacciono
e troppo e troppo strano che sappia
sempre dove siamo secondo me cup da
qualcosa ma non c'è non è che ci vede
proprio però più o meno il gioco di dice
la direzione in cui siamo credo è non lo
so vorrei essere jason almeno una volta
raga solo per capire come funziona jason
e quindi come capire come sopravvivere
meglio perché non non essendo l'ho mai
stato ecco quello che vi ho promesso il
culetto che dicono mi segue pervertito
jesus mica puoi mica questi ciano
un'asta mina che si recupera dopo due
anni la famiglia e la energia raga che
regola recuperando un anno e mezzo
mikado star fermo un ora
ok poi abbiamo un altro zio poi se
parliamo non ho mai capito se jason si
sente o meno prove
aim apriti gara sì infatti qualche jazz
un vicino un eccola la [ __ ]
eccola i've found e tanica find the rest
trovato anche le cose qua perfetto e sci
e sci e sci che se tipo perché sono
trovato qualcosa sì bene eh si come
tanto cazzo e grosso sta a casa
eh sì ok un cazzo a trovare figura sia
trovato qualcosa se non faccio io quale
cosa ne va ne sono sono pure donna mette
a fare benzina che è un lavoro maschile
sono sexy le ragazze con la benzina
ognuno dei contrari però non fate gli
uomini voi io mi siedo sul sedile non
faccio un cazzo
fatelo voi no io devo fà find this
fucking batteri please be cosa e merlot
per caffè avranno capito
salve con me ha capito subito quadrato
jason ha già sfondato tutto oppure le
loro madri tra almeno le chiavi laga
deco h vacca ma avic e controllato in
giro sto controllando solo io che qua
tutto chiuso è poca ma sapete giocare
gente più stupida di me il suo gioco
cioè non parole ma guarda mappali
lasciata lì porca vacca o minchia che
kakà vado ma avvisa prima quello quello
di prima the barella che non mi seguiva
fin qua se uscire quando faceva la mappa
porca vacca mi chiami fai cagare addosso
poi son dato tutto
ma dov'è
ma giusta scusa ma io non lo vedo non lo
sto vedendo su jason due casi sono
andato se n'è andato è sparita la musica
o find the battery click aiuto aiuto
ecco mi ha fatta il ma qua ragazzo
perché lo ha fatto
ma siccome è pieno di gente ma cosa vuoi
da me ma se pieno di gente ma robbie
caccia agli altri no no io io sto
stronzo io no è andato
porca [ __ ] maglia mi ha via via via la
finestra chiusa la finestra aperta vai
vai vai veloce
porca vacca come sono fuggito c'è di
meno al cliente [ __ ] aiuto
vincerò ormai è stagione sarà
impossibile mi dimetto etecsa mazzei
davagna porca vacca che porta poi mai
nicchia che donna una donna da sposare
la ga.fi l'uomo aiutami test the cool e
fashion che non ti spaventare per il
cadavere
se mi vedi la mattina e peggio vai vai
vai se entra in due entrati a veloce sta
picchiando lui bra grafici ma come marca
vacca fuggi fuggi dai mentre mischiata
almeno vado via io
se però sia de vico madonna quanto
quanto lindt a questa donna quanti
problemi quanto lenta ma perché occorre
però quanti madonna lega incredibile o
macori mario professione velocità
massima in cui una donna
posso mai giocare in gioco così come non
c'è altro agente ho dovuto sacrificare
il tipo di prima è un po come le donne
che usa una carta di credito del tipo io
ne so qualcosa
porca vacca sono stato malissimo
veramente pare ormai uno spray che il
deodorante orca vacca apposta zio mi
piace e botta forti almeno tu c'hai il
fucile fate allora qui abbiamo già
controllato prima non c'è una sega e
figurati la polizia arriva tra tremino
mandato non serve a niente
già provato che la polizia ha mai
successo
a meno che non mi debba far trovare in
un punto preciso non lo so
allora escape the authorities polizia
decina di cm sky cui i depositi dove
cazzo dovrebbe rivalta polizia
all'entrata spero tre minuti sono
rimasti in 3d vi porta nel 4 invece
ancora messi bene andare ci siano almeno
siamo tutti insieme proprio proviamo a
battere la gara va beh niente macchina
prima scappare con la perizia
come facciamo a scappare con la polizia
sono juan non software sky come
indebolisse ho parlato più arabo cake
inglese però thank you miyake risposta
non avete sentito ma tipo era risposta
bisognerà un transformer senti senti
thank you nei senso è parlato in
transformers lega e casoli voce a questo
hai una da transformers prince speak
with human language almeno ci prova dai
forino
comunque io dovrei capire come abbia
quello ancora che sulla macchina del
caffè
oddio cioè il fucile usa lo è usalo
perché port cava bravo bravo spa gli
asparagi bravo bravo così fargli male
arriviamo a nord va però non vedere ora
sono io ma lei l'altra parte cariparma
che ha riparata ma ora se sti stronzi
noi parla mattina quando non ci sono io
ma guarda se mi devono far incazzare o
ci mette un'ora ma dormo ci vado con te
per il mio no jason non seguire me non
seguire me per l'amore di gesù ma perché
segue me perché l'altro life
la donna che nervi o che nervi che nervi
porta di una [ __ ] che nervi che
fastidio ma gesù cristo ma iv dell'altro
uomo taj parata addosso ma a follower
rim test the cooler ammazzate va ma
[ __ ] coma gli ha sparato 1 segue me ma
che cazzo vuoi ma è matt ma segue cui il
cristo che tra sparata una cosa vuoi da
me ma [ __ ]
latina manuli terrazzati tutti
schiacciati va ma ci mancherebbe ora gal
ultimo barca e va l'ultimo mi fanno
incazzare che non fanno queste cene non
è possibile citati spacca il culo lui e
seguì me ma ci avrai dei problemi ai
neuroni ce l'avrai qualcosa di
pronunciato non lo so io
ma porca vacca l'aigam ignota ma era
riparato con la macchina che basta che
jean perdere mi fanno incazzare ma ha
senso mi fanno incazzare vi giuro mi
fanno incazzare spartito se fanno s se
desfa sito e jason me ne vado porca
vacca sono immutati a presenti kato non
so se stai visto né no perché anche voi
di censura tutto ora è impossibile ve lo
giuro match ci provo nella migliore
delle ipotesi non riesco a far niente
perché delle ipotesi la migliore delle
situazioni però io ho il mio italiano
quindi accontentate di bai hassan 40
partita che è che faccia non sono mai
jason e allora macchina manco a parlarne
figuriamoci troviamo subito alla mappa
che capiamo domanda o rega vi giuro su
quello che volete essere stavolta perdo
c'è mi incazzo di brutto non è possibile
questa è la radio serve un cazzo
beh spa sito è d'esposito ad un decorso
e 6 il burrito stato già un fucile porca
vacca venisse piano pure la mamma a
jason find the battery o di sfax la
famiglia
oddio ovvero se senti tornare in bombole
la mia moglie mi incazzo lesbico la
mappa lo trovate dalle feci testa di
cazzo ma toccato provato a fondo di pace
ma yes and non si fa a taste testa di
cazzo ma cosa vuoi più di così non so
una madre che ho trovato il coso o
regate non si fotte un fa vj a pochi
cazzi
faccio un culo così va anche i thank you
yes we be so if we can escape ai i'll
give you on ice cream sofa and the
better yen degas viso cazzo è quello
qua non ce ne risulti cassettoni c'e
solo la statua del buddha lassù c'è non
so è lesbica
gesù non c'è neanche la barca percy
cappuccio craxista parti cui scappiamo
scusami non c'è la barca non c'è dalla
macchina non c'è manco la dignità lista
parti tabù come faccia batte ammazzati
mie compagne che posso farlo io arrivato
jason subito così eccolo eccolo
ma perché vieni da me perché se pieno di
gente percorreva schifosa ma perché
vieni da me ma perché è di vita è ma è
pieno di gente perché certo al red
ti prego ditemi che avete sentito cosa
ha detto ha detto martin grice mar deve
garics 130 [ __ ] a me da me viene
da me perché io l'ho già scritto stop
c'è scritto un figlio di stronzi qua qua
qua ho scritto qua no e quindi mi
ammazzano prove ragazzo è all ex pci
io ci provo lo fa più di così martino
garics o ha detto ha detto martin grice
in una lingua inventati ma non sto io
nicolas martin ma il vero martin qua
sono io
10 comma 6 burrito d'esposito dai
l'ultima riga poi cambio va bene famo
l'ultima che porca vacca c'è verso
ora che iscrivetevi tutti al canale che
dobbiamo arrivare al 4 milioni ad agosto
che sempre nel mese guardiamo a 4
milioni iscritti
magari non ci arriviamo ai doriani i
pronostici dicono settembre ma non lo so
se dite anche alla nonna di iscriversi
ai vostri amici magari ci arriviamo
prima poi fate del vostro meglio su
slide to my channel di cosa ebbe due
iscritti tempi nel dubbio mettiamo in
mezzo anche loro nicolas martin sta
parlando ma non l'ho sempre despar sito
tua madre burrito alla gesù per partito
mi piace computer di della patata
possono il computer quanto ci metti a
caricare fastidio ma vi pre prevedo che
sono jason in questa partita no perché
lo sono sempre quindi magari lo sono
anche in questa così fermiamoci ancora
di più per il culo sporco schifo va al
mondo dei verso il 6 burrito sì sì sì
technique rimorchio l'alcol fa ci da
gallipoli e poi arriva gente rovina la
festa al solito scarico
sono sei brutto
la tua madre femmine
cosa vuol dire five minutes to survive
scusami se quello che dice all'inizio
five minutes survive
ma che fai mi inizia una partita dura
sei ore se non io non so ancora i tasti
porca vacca cosa ci avvicino macchine
manca a pagarle
ma stavolta scatto sa come scappo con un
bear chiamo huber col perer il taxi taxi
a milano grazie
subito arriva prima porca vacca almeno
ci sia mesi la vita possa mickey è
incredibile mi carica mi piace un sacco
la rai perché poi non doveva montare il
video il trastullo tranquillo
esatto proprio questo volevo fare
credimi non volevo fare mica altro e
questo lo fa perfetto ma normali dei
comandi sto gioco sugli obiettivi o la
mappa almeno quelle da me lo vedo
vediamo quante macchine ci sono ma
neanche una 12 due tizi sulla macchina
io sono qua in mezzo gas thank quindi
hanno già messo il gas nella macchina
bene trovare una batteria le chiavi e
vaffan cuore va figure centro
io sono qui quindi andando verso di loro
che di qua c'è una macchina c'è una casa
nel mezzo e potrei provare a trovare le
chiavi vai vai o la tanica vediamo
contro albero che sembra il tasto m
posso vedere a che punto sono arrivati
fantastico mica ti prego dai vi prego
una volta una volta sola non vi chiedo
altro che michele video di l'altro ieri
ma non per investito stile bici una nata
solo la tanica veramente solo la tanica
solo quello vi prego che le chiavi le
trovano loro hanno sento né la mancata
anni che nelle chiavi nella tanica
vigore un cazzo un cazzo ma quando mai
mmm oggi esco vado con jason mi tira
un'ascia e perfino jason figuranti si
accendono non era qua figura di ragazze
stiamo ragazza stato ma c'è tutto c'è
tutto c'è macario la chiave la chiave le
chiavi cazzo mano le chiavi lega e chi
ha fretta e non al 3 set erano un po
prima in una presa ed è che non c'è e
non ci sono buttato le chiavi
minchia che sfiga sono le troviamo ora
ganci credo ora che trovate le chiavi
hanno fatto incazzare
salve buongiorno trovato le chiavi lei
tutta la che caga [ __ ] che cagà ma
perché devi
se n'è andato
bastava star no è entrato in casa tutta
una vacca occhio è però dovete entrare
subito una volta sono riuscito a
sfuggire la così la prima volta che ho
fatto il video di venerdì 13 poi tutte
le altre volte mi ha sempre [ __ ]
sotto il letto
ma stavolta sono fiducioso
poi mica non è che le sfila
tranquillamente questa porca vacca che
fastidio madonna
[Musica]
minchia peccato dell'armadio no no no
non sia uno zio è figura che figures ma
figurazioni tech
vabbè basta bassanese rotto il cazzo
bastardi flash calamento di palle
inutile a gesù cristo
nora che imposto giochi possibile non
finirà mai
ottima anche un pezzo non finire mai
possibile da fini a venerdì 13
c'è trovi sempre genere poi se io sono
jason scapperebbero tutti è però non
riesco mai a vincere mai sfidarsi o ci
ho provato e ci ho provato avete visto
tutti senza tagli quindi io ce la metto
sempre tutta non c'è verso cambiamo
ragazzi player non batto il grande che
almeno faccio un po di roba più carine
sono vai tutta la cow ci fosse mezza
volta che riesca a vincere ogni chef
verso non mi dispiace perché non è un
gioco che da meritocrazia è l'unica roba
brutta almeno tipo questo non è anche
questo da merito creato un cazzo da
meritocrazia non è un gioco che da
meritocrazia perché magari ti fai in
culo trovi tutto gli altri non fanno un
cazzo vuoi piano la macchina e se ne
vanno e tu hai tu magari hai messo la
tanica emesso le chiavi tutto è messo
fuori e gli altri due scappano
tranquilli a [ __ ] poi la regola del
gioco è sempre questa ci sono otto
giocatori più o meno tre o quattro
scappano quindi ai 50 per cento della
vita di scappare 4 scappano ma tra quei
quattro tu stai tranquillo che non ci
sei mai non si sa perché si vince se si
vince al programma quello che vince non
sarai mai turno non si sa perché tutti
sono così qui c'è qualcuno che vince ma
non ne ho mai sopravvissuto per
raccontarlo vinceranno dei bot
non lo so manes c'è ma è strano sta roba
non sarete mai voi a vincere o gioco
vinceranno sempre gli altri
peccato perché ho fatto quattro partite
anche abbastanza belle però c'è anche
chi ha preso
perché ai comandi
va bene che cerchiamo ap l'iran non sa
però che questo lo conosciate più o meno
tutti che almeno nei più è un po più
fattibile a mandarli dai prendiamocela
subito nel culo
vediamo rugger ma pratici comandi di
steve
forse ho staccato l'ho staccato il
joystick e mark rasch alla live al
massimo sta col mouse è tutto a posto
allora gaga per chi non conoscesse
questa roba
l'obiettivo e vedete quel 93 in alto a
destra
quel 93 diventare uno nel senso che
quelli sono 93 i giocatori ancora vivi
io sono l'unico stronzo che muore per
quello si sa è l'obiettivo arrivare
arrivare privi quindi ammazzare tutti
gli altri o meglio sopravvivere a tutti
gli altri tipo questo qualche calcio di
saper the park è tutto un altro stronzo
non ci sono team almeno che qualcuno sia
leggono qualcun altro li proposito
perfetto vediamo se riesco subito a
giocare di brutto
magari non cadere sugli edifici in cui
cado io no perfetto meno male mese all e
in questo sono abbastanza bravino però
proprio perché ho detto questa cosa mi
ammazzeranno subito però va ginger
canzone qua dentro che lo sento correre
con una iena in calore morta ho trovato
la tanica ho trovato la tanica qua
porca [ __ ] ma com'e cambiato già
gioco è diverso ma non mi serve più io
sento uno che corre come un bastardo qui
non dite niente non di non dite niente
non voglio sentire proferire parola
non voglio sentire niente city fitti
rete stare zitti
zitti proprio possiamo cambiare il
titolo della live nel da spacco i culi a
spacco il culo della mamma di chi mi
uccide magari magari cambia la sito una
vacca o una forza molto schivo ma ma ma
poi ben shahn feller
poi io vi ho trovato una pistola di
melfi con un fucile ma figure è
maledetta la vita maledetta la vita che
qua miglia gesù cristiano ma perché ho
una porca di una mappa poi perché è
venuto da me ma cosa cazzo vuoi ricaduta
dall altro edificio sei uscito perché
viene cazzo invece va incredibile ho
veramente assurdo
un mese di vita si io sono più forte
fronte ci ho creduto in questa cosa che
ho detto quanto è durata la mia serietà
dopo che l'ho detto ma al ragazzo di tua
sorella morta questo molti si chiedono
che cosa che mi dico se all'inizio che
disparate tutti questi match making non
serva un cazzo solo perché dobbiamo
arrivare a 100 giocatori e poi
puntualmente siamo sempre in 97 98 non
arriva mai al 100
variamo subito di nuovo porca [ __ ] se
mi si avvicina uno risparmi lanciarazzi
nel culo dentro la popoli di costrutti
giri modonna madonna non ha idea
faccio come lei per le api in fila
farisei né tullo lei del video di anima
ve la do andiamo qua salve stiamo dando
una testata fortissimo questo io con
tizio [ __ ] vacca schifo mar
vabbè non pensavo mai di vincere anche
solo una partita in questa live è però
almeno se comunque lo faccio vedere io
brutta frase che ho detto
assaggiate mia involtino o non c'è
nessuno raga sono caduto da solo per una
volta nessuno che caga le palle madonna
che che è che che sollievo guarda ma che
sollievo
allora questa è la casa dei puffi ci
trovo mai un pene di divertente pensa
veramente che nessuno caputo qua
tranquilli mica un minute ma arriva un
carro armato che non ci sono istituti
carrarmati ma se lei creato ea mi
arrivarono per il ca sicuro è gesù cioè
prima sono riuscita a morire tra i primi
non mi è mai successo c in creso durato
un secondo incredibile però trovato la
tanica di spa tua madre ora sono nella
seguito questo cerchio vian porca vacca
non so saltare le associate questo
cerchio bianco e la zona sicura se non
la raggiungo entro il tempo che c'è in
basso a destra quello che sono quattro
minuti e 50 arriva al gas che noi la ton
nel gas e una parete elettrica che mi
uccide se sono fuori dai debiti quindi
il pian piano giochi di un cerchio si
restringe sempre di più fino a che non
arriva un'area strettissima questo è il
gioco per chi non lo conoscesse così
alla fine ci incontriamo tutti bene o
male per forza perché cerchio si
restringe tantissimo fino a che non ci
ammazziamo tutti e rimane uno solo e
vinciamo la partita dura tipo cinque
minuti perché poi gli inculano però se
non mi curassero durerebbe un po di più
tipo una ventina o o tommy jarvis
pistola a gas
mica se prima se prima avevo un fucile
madonna li squartava anche la faccia
però figura
come mai così tanti oggi che casa non
c'è la ragazza per nessuna bravi bravi
guarda caso di arrivare 4 milioni
iscritti prima di settembre
l'altra tani mpa per il culo sto gioco
c'è anche quale cani che mai che si
trovano così facilmente le trovo ovunque
mancano le chiavi è perfetto come non
detto subito proprio mancano le chiavi
della macchina e la batteria nella
materia mese
però la macchina da troverò mai avessi
gas
cazzo
gesù per anno per due amici e stavo già
fomentando la partenza gioco si trovi il
cecchino di mirino da cecchino sei un
dio ho trovato nel video fatto l'altro
giorno prima partita vanno cecchino
subito qua ma figura neanche tra
vent'anni però almeno trovarla meno male
che c'era un tetto sotto perché mi stava
ammazzando almeno trovare un'arma
decente non sarebbe male
l'export di vetro buono comunque rai ha
solo perché voi siete in live vi spoiler
ho questa cosa in scrittura nuovo pezzo
con ipantellas nuova parodia in arrivo o
cecchino cioè almeno da cecchino
quell'ostacolo scrauso air non è più
forte ma almeno posso sembrare figo
manca adesso al pezzo di importante che
il fucile come ho trovato il mirino è
banca al suo cile però è al limite gli
diro il mirino in testa almeno se della
coppa comunque solo per voi che siete in
live perché il live quando sono in live
faccio sempre rivelazioni che così non
sa nessuno tranne voi
nuovo pezzo che sono sempre tante
l'espresso in arrivo così ragazze e
trans in italy arrivata quasi a 13
milioni e tantissimo che tantissimo c'è
veramente in pochissimo tempo ha
superato anche il mio bimba basta
steccati di tali che va beh il
pochissimo tempo è diventato uno dei
miei video più visti i razzi di cuore ho
già detto grazie però ragazzi così
almeno adesso facciamo una nuova parodia
facciamo le big news tutori e non è
detto però tra poco li facciamo a
saperlo
mi raccomando fate iscrivere tutti i
vostri amici nostra madre la nonna è il
mio canale che arriviamo a 4 milioni
prima di di settembre create anche altri
account e iscrivetevi grazie quanto in
modo esplicito
scherzo ovviamente da uno scherzo
[Musica]
a posto io sto saccheggiando case come
un caimano look è una cosa che non vi ho
mai detto quando faccio i miei eventi
tipo mi sembra di giocare a questo gioco
perché quando mi mandano nel camerino no
c'è sempre tipo la red bull che questa
il cose da mangiare
ce n'è sempre un sacco no io quando vado
via minchia più un sacchetto in filo
tutte dentro come uno sciacallo
maledetto me li porta a casa a caso mi
sembra di parcheggiare le case tipo in
questo gioco uguale non trova mai vicini
è nemmeno male però trovo sacco di roba
da mangiare o uffici le miglia porto
tutto a casa come se niente fosse una
padella abbiamo vinto la roma la
distruzione di massa ce l'abbiamo
allora questo cielo questo cielo questo
cielo non sta messo bene l'unica roba
che manca è fucile a da cecchino ma
qualche mirino anche effettivamente non
saremo mai stato adesso non supera
equiparato primo che vedo mi in cura per
due ore basta prendere cose primo che
vedevi mi fa un culo che la metà bassa
per aiuti camminavo c'era qualcuno mi
sono sbagliato non c'è qualcuna ragazzi
cc c'è qualcuno raga
cc
che cazzo è
praga c'è un tizio non so dove mi no
come cazzo
mentana
aveva superato la finestra di mortacci
mia sparate alla finestra ho sbagliato
io
fatto malissimo regale
fontana che è male ma fatto che cazzo
vuoi della vita mia
dai tutta la [ __ ] perché non ne faccio
un'altra non è possibile perché perché
perché perché nei colpi sono fatti di
gomma perché non segue sempre me ma
[ __ ] [ __ ] che fastidio gesù cristo
c'è proprio i miei proietti neanche
scalfiscono la gente incredibile c'è bo
amareggiato regalo
ma la prossima carico di sfascio anche
alla famiglia che sia ago chiunque sia
certo erano era pure uno scarso che ho
detto poco 22 il numero due ma che poi
top per sé mieli youtuber fa vj e dice
porcu e non è una bestemmia
dicevo se mi ha indicato cosa stavo per
dicendo oppure a sichera 3 scasso come
lo schifo colorata che si sentivano un
tango km
mi aspettavo in una zona bruttissima e i
suoi gli sparo in faccia non muore come
anche uno scarso e non sono forte porca
vacca scarso di merda barra
tanto siamo un'ora di live dai raga
facciamo così mi sono deciso ultima qua
a preghiera non e poi ne facciamo ancora
uno di 13 tottenham o ultima venerdì 13
poi ha così succo di brutto un'ultima
volta e siamo tutti contenti
va bene poi basta
[Musica]
pietro che mi ha scritto che sono scalzi
la mamma di apporti attrae ha mai visto
ne sbatte in faccia pietro gli ho
sparato in faccia fortissimo che minchia
anche sua madre si è spaventata non è
morto che non fare o fili così non so
non è morto manco per sbaglio e my live
è normale la legge della live non farei
mai una partita buona perché il live non
andare sempre male nelle partite dico
sempre sempre così
quali proviamo dai 23 prevenire anche tu
pietro su venerdì 6 venire di amy
scriverò su whatsapp che divieto in ps
primo a fare una di 13 mi sentiva ad ora
[ __ ]
da solo c'è un tizio da giugno bene ma
mi sono rotto il cazzo pio ii robben al
volo e me ne vado devo trovare il
cecchino subito che sono un inculano se
sparo alle persone devono morire morire
devono morire mi interessa sono me la
famiglia che non dice come sacco di
gente in lei la partita è piena di gente
che sta guardando la live che sa dove
sono
ecco perché quello bastardo vidi prima
sapeva dove ero a pezzo di merda perché
guardi la live q la famiglia non ci ho
pensato a testa dico da un cecchino che
però fanno schifo questo è però è già
qualcosa
mi chiamo ci ho pensato perché mi aveva
visto la la rai aveva facile così è
bravo complimenti perché era in una zona
dove non era caduto nessuno era i limiti
della mappa quindi era impossibile che
qualcuno venisse a uccidere
ricevo come cassetti qualcun altro che è
impossibile perché c'è di sembrare ha
sentito male quando ho sentito i suoi
passi perché hai visto la lav è bravo
destra di culo bravo avvantaggiati pure
nel giocare che da solo non mi farei
siculo ma manco a pagarlo
ecco perché ma non ci sono scarsoni di
merda che ha visto mia vedeva dovere in
l'area grazie al cazzo lescano chiusi
mica non c'era arriva un pc con un cielo
coppa arrivato fante piemontese la
parola picio scusate era che ogni tanto
mi parte ii ha letto dialetto questo
dialetto però la bagna cauda né festa di
adesso per 4 scott lo metto sul fucile a
pompa il mirino per 4 il caso lo metto
perché ci avevo cecchino prima l'ho
buttato per terra per 2 mp perché mi fa
cagare quel cecchino ragazzo veramente
cagare quel cecchino
la cosa più schifosa abbia mai visto
levan è anche se il implori leva auto
out e tutti i disegni mi ricordavo sera
raffica di tre corpi si spara tutti i
colpi che possiamo che mi arriva che chi
sia in live che sia un fan che sia un no
mikel implode la famiglia sensi però
almeno ci provo
mica forcaiola suonarla penali e di
gadget fantastico o lo so che viene a
far così [ __ ] missimi colpi però c'è
veramente sono due incroci dove sticazzi
[ __ ]
la prima è preferisco il bomba marca
vacca
preferisco usare un fucile a pompa e
un'arma d'assalto perché se tenevo
l'armani clima anche se la pena di gli
aggeggi il gadget
almeno così ha un'arma ravvicinata è
un'arma alla distanza invece prima avevo
due armi d'assaggio dove la zona sicura
vicina perfetto nicchia di cestino sotto
la missione mi fa sempre credere dei
colpi più piccolo dei calci per sbaglio
che bello farle live in mutande
perché sono un professionali youtuber
non mi si vede con questo che potrei
fare anche nudo sono che mi sarei un po
disagio è un bravo
o fullback minchia però veramente tre
colpi croce porca vacca lo trovare i
colpi verdi mi fa incazzare il suo gioco
che a volte stai due ore a trovarle robe
sisimica tutto cedute è pari a uno
stronzo mevoli prima gli spari in faccia
non muore da mazza ha quindi sparato
prima io volo e fa ridere
quand'è che si restringe la zona e tra
poco 40 secondi i ragazzi mano
un attimo ragazza che mi vado a prendere
un bombolone alla crema
io faccio le live con le serie
le dai di quelle serie proprio
professionale youtuber ngcongca va male
del mondo lonia dopo un giorno spero di
no che bello mangiare davanti a 40 mila
persone a caso mi piaceva una fame
dai mi chiama un cecchino una volta
nella vita non mi arriva a jason a caso
tutta la sicurezza tra un cecchino una
volta nel secolo
c'è nessuno
o meno male aiutato quando corro sono un
bisonte mi senti che comunque va bene
scazzi ci dovrei fare piano in teoria ma
piano in termini che non conosco neanche
nel sesso che si badi non sparate non
sparate
l'ultima casa e controllo che devo
correre perché arriva la cosa blu e il
gas che amico mi chiamano sono nato è
riuscito a sopravvivere a un
restringimento di gas
c'è inv all'assurdo
cazzola ma figurati se trovo un cecchino
maledetto mamma mia
tanto da riprovare a che il mirino c'è
chi nel mirino insieme se è un'altra
vita con quello che ci arriva a jason
col machete di fa un culo tanto
no
un cazzo la mente cosa vuol dire un
tasso trovato un cazzo quello che piace
è la mia ex vediamo dove arriva ancora
devo muovere il culo
niente niente cecchin ora che ho trovato
bene sono messo più o meno dai più o
meno visto di fermo ecco ho puntato 26
condomini ma mi passò per stato di choc
ma non mi stupirei neanche ora
fate uno screenshot quando
dichiarava a del una fan e ponte florio
ma qui non c'è neanche una casa neanche
mezzo ma qua c'è una porta aperta o ciò
porte aperte significa che la parte
qualcuno significa che ci apriamo nel
culo dai dai che questa me la sento
quando dai 49 alive è già la metà dei
giocatori sono andata a kultan è ok
ma possibile che il tipo che è uscito
all in one venuti vita a casa possibile
veramente dipende se trovo cose [ __ ]
vuol dire che non è passato sennò vuol
dire che è passato e mi sta attendendo
un'imboscata soppresso marcava casolari
non sono scuole il meglio di due come
accoglie e cioè su preso il pari pompa
tralcio che che silenziatore è la donna
che cazzo è un è un tweak è un must
c'è una barretta di cioccolato enorme da
zero prima una cosina ucciso è freeware
6 amazon.com è ancora vicina di casa
heather mi devo andare a figure toglierò
mai e server
la polizia polizia muncipale che è un
ace di una cosa per il cerchino figurati
se da un cecchino
nel doppio e colpi li prendo cari sono i
colpire il cecchino per una ciechi
occhio
e cos'è
ora sì che sono gli occhi spazio casi
non saper prendere niente
devo muovere il culo tra l'altro ogni
parte che ho detto io io tanica tutta
per un attimo creole vetro trovato il
cecchino erotico minchia non ci posso
credere
figure ricorso croce che mi chiede un
attimo tipo li ho visto questa roba è
normale tu no vabbè ora cecchino era il
mio perde via via via di qua via devo
correre sono in cura gas mai verrai 37
alive è ma senza c'è chi potrà anche
pensare di ammazzare una voce questo è
il gas gas che non e gassman rete
elettrica però non so perché si dice che
altri cioè fitch e gas perché manca un
oggetto a 1 si giocasse nomi spunta uno
mi troverò per i [ __ ] so io ti
ammazzo un tipo e quello cioè il
cecchino mano piglio problema che come
l'ammazzo un tipo che al cecchino nei
miei sogni 34 lai braga siamo nei
migliori 25 per no 34 per cento di
giocatori piuttosto rapido calcolo
mentale
bene anche 13 syraka adesso fisco questa
lo faccio
finisco questa nel senso vinco questo e
lo faccio ci sei pietro per venerdì 13
cosa mi ha scritto non mi ha scritto
niente ma glielo chiedo io
vieni a fare vela di 13 uomo venisse ts
dai ha specificato the sun in live
magari pensava di giocare che per i
cazzi miei
il live ovviamente le praterie ai di
andata allora c'è una città sola tutta
prateria la zona finale questa ciò vuol
dire che avesse lista zona qua
significa avere il cecchino perché se
non è il cecchino non ci devi andare in
queste zone perché è tutto aperto
quindi per l'api intercooler se non c'è
il cecchino problema è che la zona
sicura è questa quindi sono costretto a
stare qua per adesso è anche per dopo e
tutti avranno cecchino quindi tutti si
spara nei chilometri di distanza e io no
perché sono stronzo poi aperto figura
quindi se non trovo un cecchino finito
di vivere come lo trovo cecchino non lo
farò mai ho perso praticamente mano che
il tipo non abbiamo trovato qua ma credo
difficile se l'altra stanza aperta ma
con una macchina o vero niente ero di
cazzo poi aperto se aperto inter non ci
dovrebbe essere anche nessuno tua aperto
lasciato lì
dai porca vacca fastidio che la mia
discorso pietro ci son è bravo pietro
bravo lago dai che dopo c'è anche pietro
in live che in 2 riusciamo a fare più
schifo di me da solo 27 al hiver figure
caso cis però fare come l'altro strong
che nell'altro video sono arrivato in
top 2 1 contro 1 il tipo poteva essere
poteva non avere niente allo stare solo
un fucile dello schifo giorni j killed
by thing faccio dice uno che si chiama
djokovic e dicevo potrà avere anche un
fucile veramente schifoso e ha vinto la
partita perché solo contro di me e non
l'ho visto lui mi ha sparato
quindi torniamo cioè sto gioco poi anche
non avere un cazzo
poi c'è passato qualcuno in prove mi
serve il mirino
scarse passati di qua scusa tutto tutto
occupato impossibile
madonna a me c'era la la zona dove si
sta restringendo ecco è questa che
minchia è una prateria devasta ma porca
vacca ma che sfiga o poco incredibile
che sfiga assurda che palle c'è un senso
cecchino è freeware due volte hanno più
spazio neanche proprio zero potuti
perdere ciò che ciò che il mirino sono
state l'ho trovato cecchino la zona lì
mica sarà la donna stava facendo un
party ci stanno facendo ci vado schiato
però devo andare lì per forza celata non
per forza fra tutti i quattro vivi e ha
già giocato bene siamo meglio di un
quarto dei giocatori e della partita
c'è nessuno
ma possibile che io in tutta la partita
non l'ho incontrato nessuno ma neanche
mezza per mazar doni e nessuno e credevo
tutta una vacca ace bunker laggiù
sì ma non ci parla o meglio se ci vado
io non ci vado ci vado non ci vado ma
non per 4 niente mirino pure più forte
ci vado ma adesso non so se c'è una idea
vero ma tanto sarà già tutto lui c'erano
già questo tutto quindi figurati se
trovo qualcosa ma neanche un morto
mica pensavo fosse una persona per un
attimo e poi mi sono ricordato che non
cespuglio
minchia sono pagato troppo fortissimo
c'è niente figura se c'è qualcosa
figurati protesterò vabbè allora posso
trovato un caso un pene di niente
vediamo questi restringe ancora che
magari bunker si può rivelare utile al
se si restringe sembra aveva sentito di
passo
se si restringe su di me sono a posto ci
pensa tese a zona finale quest'album
karmica pino che scende ma non allo zo
livello
figurati allora io sono qua la zona
sicura tutta questa voce una città spero
vivamente che non si restringerà cuamm
associare stile stringerli lo vediamo
subito ragazzi da come si restringe il
cerchio in 3 2 1 e quando mai
quindi devo andare
madonna prateria pura cibo prateria aver
a quanto minuto 44 mi conviene aspettare
che si restringa al cerchio e andare
mentre
madonna ragazzi kakà
storo more like an la [ __ ] [ __ ] alla
luce il piccolo creatori volato sarà un
tizio io qualsiasi fa anche un gradino
vedo un tizio al posto del gradino non
so perché nel partito il corpo su facile
cobham
ma quale già controllato si cercasse
domande fascia
domanda retorica questa parte che
secondo me se c'è pure qualcuno dentro
qua no è aperto aperto la crema natale
già inserite dai
c'è una macchina c'era una [ __ ]
macchina quindi potrebbe esserci
qualcuno anzi sicuramente c'è qualcuno
va beh per forza dai piace la l'uscita
vabbè sti caxxi allora vediamo se
possiamo metterci per farsi sparare
subito
mi converrebbe aspettare qualcuno sotto
la macchina
peccato
mica qua si è fermato
figure 0 mazzeo il tentativo c'era
cagasotto mi sono fatto sentire da tutta
la mappa più o meno bene sono contento
apple è sceso tizio prescelto dalla
macchina da sé aria di sfida come era
l'unica è l'unica sarà equipaggiato
molto meglio di me quindi mi farà un
culo così infatti che queste non ci
arriva il cecchino pure chi cazzo mi sta
sparando barca h fastidio che qui si
farà ma chi ma dove a [ __ ] ma dove
ahia ahia
non ci sto capendo ragazzate dietro
sicuro però un capitolo re zog e pieno
di 13 a tanto era o rimasti in 12 wow
nice
denis zio vieni su tst speak forte che
nette
eccolo zhao hongo aspettare non so se ti
ci si sente greta spoiler foglio di
carta di morto
eh si non va bene così e mi hanno
sondato dalla collina di gesù cristo
hai capito hai capito quanto sono figli
di [ __ ] non descrive la lo so
poi quando non siamo in live vinciamo
quando siamo in live che fate adesso
entriamo in gioco e moriamo subito certo
viene siamo in live poi spegniamo la
live primi si chiama ecco la torta ci
chiama anche il creatore del gioco per
facendo un primo per il live facciamo
pagare come come dio comanda mi sembra
giusto io stavo giocando tetris quindi
pensa monte comero messo questo
giochiamo arriverà di entra ma ti si
sente seta fai sentire con le casse
collegate aiuto aiuto bravissimo se ti
si sente stai parlando da solo però
sentono più facile per immagini credo
che se non mi sentono di boss entrate
che parli da solo ma non si sente un
cazzo non sapete fare ma sento io no mi
sento mi sento ma che se non frega
oleico fermarci qua come si chiama aresi
piga dai sei andato per un attimo o mi
raccomando subito è perdiamo perché sono
tiriamo avanti in coppa la prima la
prima il primo stronzo di ieri player o
no che mi è uscito dalla casa ma don
ascoli fi con pompa in testa non è ma io
ho visto quello aperto live certo punto
ci ritorna a casa e sci muori quando si
comincino attorno e muore ancora
l'organismo style
finché non vuole la gente io mi meglio
ce lo metto dai dai vai vai limitato
parti 26 amica effettivamente vi sono
offline
se un genio
66 ei guida perché wake up its bastrop
6th in dj non ci sei
noi non mi inviti evitate o tre volte
porta l'anziana di mancato qualcosa dice
che ha avviato dai che fastidio quando
accettare una partita hai capito gerry
scotti o perché up ci siamo
no non ti vedo perché io tu ci sei
scusami ti faccio cosplay ti va bene non
ti vedo in picture poi vita mia la
partita port cantante madonna che c'è
difficile più arrivino a bartok e di
farlo perché stavano in parte di faraday
stampati sei un giovane limitato 6
joining mai cercata partita per l'amore
di di rick play si patto madonna che
caldo fa cosca luce di punta in faccia
non l ho vinciano per l'amore di dio
almeno una partita ormai vinta in tutta
la nostra vita figure del live
figurativa
smau preference avere la sua preferenza
lo vede io non ce l'ho
niente adesso mi incazzo la voce niente
però cioè hai cercato stai giocando lì
siamo in searching fu dedication server
calcio il 38 secondi 39 40 è lesbica
[Musica]
madonna che caldo veste che fa oggi ho
deciso di parlare quando fai un fa un
caldo bestiale è infatti io con centro
accedo che dura tempo danno che palle
quanto ci manca o searching fashion from
forse sì eccoci sai hai dentro chi sei
no no e no
martino garruzzo io non mi vedo dente
perché sei caricando a ok adesso si è
poi detto già infatti lead esigenze
sanguinis invito io ma come siamo il
fatto che siamo in là
se non riusciamo a giocare normalissima
accetta le voci vere dai accetta invita
di nuovo perché ero impatti anche tutto
questo errore non è che adesso è ok
joining parti vai aerei ma gesù io sono
una che il tradito subito entrato a me
che cazzo di problemi allora che
speriamo che ti entry che se non ti
entra gioca solo già che faccio pagare
almeno fammi giocare
ok sono date koleff the party bjp del
por ti sei film che problemi altro pc
oggi vi era nessuno giocando avrà
provincia spetta
ti invito di nuovo invito invitato vai
prova joining parti e fin qui no alla
partita dei suini parti sono io dai
proviamo l'ultima volta live per la
siamo parti insieme quickplay l'ultima
dai nove parti ovest e cavolo poi parti
vabbè velivolo scena
però il caricamento e visto giochi un po
schifo non c'è niente sono le mani dei
nozze di jason o più o meno le mie
periodo mezza faccia il collo tutto
rugoso marca vacca fa un caldo bestiale
acceso il pinguin no perché fa casino
bravo si aspetta un'altra camera
clothing ci sono o che strano dizione
speriamo che cresce il gioco è giusto
ora ecco rai la rai non lo so io ho
montato tutti perché sommano casino fa
un caldo della perizia
questo l'ha messo da dire invece sa i
giovani questo addio veramente perché lì
acini the laws minchia nome si chiama si
sta da lievi ma basta un'altra barca
no però ha cominciato l'arci do io 5
secondi allora come vogliamo scappare
stavolta mi sembra che siamo esperti di
di fughe la wada the family friendly
c'è una nota perché almeno quello
la johansson gesù sarei mai gesto ma
vero
gesù poi ricevo visto che siamo esperti
pro player di questo gioco ma vogliamo
scappare barca in macchina a piedi
io io non mi prendere per il culo perché
poi quando mi ammazzano
mi girano le palle vino mi prendevano a
culo ok non si scappa sto gioco non si
può scappare non si vince buttavano
l'altra volta che ti hanno investito a
ben altra volta l'iva che avete le prove
miei neuroni non stavo guidando io ero
un tipo a caso che guidò un dà la colpa
ai 5 secondi e 1 2 e jason con torino
vacca analogici nel 1800
ah se sei in gesù però non mi fai
vincere col calcio sinai e mese normale
pessima figura
ma hai smesso di parlare loro valore è
allora andiamo andiamo nella casa quella
destra da venire io posso guardare la
juve è vero nemico ammazzarlo jamie qua
o al cazzo non si gioca sta roba loro
figo come si fa si riprende bing
maggiore canzone si è opposto scusami eh
no la carta perché discesa la categoria
donne come si fa ad andare avanti
no questo e dico apparente devi stare lì
per due minuti e fini tutti quanti per
il bonus a destra ma ammazzati che 2006
evidente la freccia provata che cazzo
vuoi se lei che murphy location multipli
puoi andare in una location gara amica
capisco un sacco ciao ti senti miliardo
ma zia mi chiama quindi tutti poi
teletrasportare in una location ma mi
chiama allora ma [ __ ] de puoi
farlo
ciao come stai
no dico no non ti spacco la porta primi
il 23 24 ma spero vedo dopo perché
doveva spaccare una tipa subito a spacco
subito proprio bello scaldiamo però
tutto bene ti vengo a prendere anche la
famiglia sua moglie tameka 99 rai è
incredibile sono troppo contento sono
tre punte pratica ripeto aprirla con la
mano la porta ma io lo sfondo perché gli
olo ma non corre jason quindi ancora una
catenina e basta
hai un matrimonio che è bello jason sia
l'ho sentito che c'era tensione quindi
qui
salve per giorno la centese ronnie on
accesi ma ok ma che cazzo elettrico
ufficiale o ficcato una di quelle botte
imparare anche perché sparisce certi
poteri che il cazzo ho ucciso l'uomo
invisibile che userà uno che era
invisibile dello sfigato delle
coltellate morto come faccio a prendere
la gente proprio a prenderla con tasto
sinistro destro si andrà musicato a 3
maria c'è una tipa che sta parlando in
chat quindi so per ammazzare le persone
c'è anche una tipa mi dispiace non sono
io
anzi di una tipa che locale la voce era
simile io ho mai colto nei sogni rossi è
una maglia arancione e nera a strisce
con i bordi bianchi ma no non toccarmi
rift è già morgan scelti sarebbe come
faccio primi i primi tre e la madonna
hai visto che tipo va dall che figata
cosa ho fatto è stato è stato bellissimo
quanto dura e possono ma io posso anche
da trasportare
proprio lì puoi fare tutto giornata di
regata ecco come facevano a vedere le
cose vedo attraverso i muri vedo un
cerchio che si illumina grazie al calcio
e capiscono della gente mica sega è
semplice essere jason poi ovviamente io
quando sono un personaggio corno minuto
loro c'hanno la ferrari però almeno ho
capito un sacco di cose tanto ti vedo
che sei lì dentro teche scarpe con chi
stai parlando con la tipa anno a te ti
vengo a prendere un pò c'entra quello
grazie grazie ma forse non ti vengo a
prendere come si chiama tipo che sta
rincorrendo prima che vengo anch'io
penso io la mia mazza pastai col nome ma
che so ma vabbè ma sembra indicare la
sua forma pronta questa macchina lesbica
a lesbica vieni fuori alesi di caccia in
macchina così pronto allora lo sai
davvero più è quella di destra
la gente non ci sono le macchine dove la
macchina di destra c'era una macchina a
destra di quella che destra le due
volumi a destra ea sinistra
non vedo nessuna macchina design di
evitare trasporto sull'unica che c'è
cullato non c'e nessuno che la sta
toccando la macchina ha maledetto sei
uno stronzo stalking java leggono per la
direttiva cos'è lo stalker
lo store che il lo stalker è quello che
di segue ho capito è lo store che
sarebbe un gene seguono aquilano sorical
senso io leggo che per ora hanno fatto
fuori solo uno che era metri visibile
non l'ho ben capito problem agatha che
sono jason perché stava aspettando la
prima pole secondo aperta e graziosi la
vedo in streaming ma se il pezzo di
merda ma sarai strozzo dove la gente
alla mia famiglia pietro
una là davanti quindi non sarà qui come
minimo pon a cui avevo già sondato
occhio occhio jason ha detto ti spacco
la famiglia dove guardare fortuna ma la
porta mi scrisse vero mi serve ma
smettila a destra fans non ho visto il
calcio sei un maledetto pezzo di merda
mi aspetto che deve arrivare fin laggiù
come si fa da continui o la pena fino al
massimo basta malaria aiutare anch'io
vincere errore sei tu quello che manca
la tanica di benzina quindi cosa
rispetto non ti ammazzo subito ciao
fratello come stai aveni perché erasmi
si fa a fare il dexter non abbiamo
accennato mia ficcato un coltello però
sta tentando di colpirmi mayors il
faccio un culo rame da base madonna
molto di lei ho visto che sei ok uno
l'ha uccisa poi faccio uccide la gente
prendendola con l'altro tasto vedi l'è
presa vi si tu hai una tanica dove cazzo
stand la macchia che nei curatissima e
ove non so darmi una mano e zitto che
qua vedo qualcuno in caso vedo delle
cose non ho capito se c'è qualcuno che
si sta nascondendo cosa che figata
le palle per tecnico io laser
lucidissimo naziha incredibile dovessero
molto prima che come tutte le romano
sono oggetti con cui interagire
vediamo prima dove vedo la gente lo vedo
anche attraverso la mappa no
minchia adesso sì che ho capito come
funziona a jason ma cazzo sei dato che
gli che correvi tutele maledetto di
cazzi toi che alzava lesbico questa
messa la macchina qua salve la macchina
non sa caga nessuno ma messo in giro
questa prova di benzina che non hanno
capito che cazzo fare si sta cagando la
macchina perché è perché sono scarsi ok
ma quando la polizia che succede mai a
parlarne ammazzati due quindi 2 su 6
ok è arriva la polizia non so perché la
serie a dopo la sosta r questo il tasto
r
non lo so fare qua sicuramente c'è ma da
adesso per come di prima ok prime non mi
sa di aver capito dove la gente a 2 il
senso sensore ciao siete qua e brutti
stronzi india che vi spacco la porta mi
spacco la porta vista vi ammazzo
anche le famiglie nella casa di prima
noi dice del trasporto tv ha sicuramente
infatti ci sarà qualcuno io che sono
guarito ma ne vedo e invece e invece no
e invece scorso
pace in culo c'è una incredibile siete
trasportata dentro casa che curi che
cos'è 4 backstage famiglia sezione extra
per gente il vecchio aspetta di chiamato
sta giocando con questa salve salve
signora come sta tutto a posto a madonna
che bello questo gioco anche se un sacco
la prua eccola dove la cura ma butta ma
se cava mai capito i noti c'è la barca e
prodotti si tratti ma chi non ce l'ha
perché non senso della polizia e ti dà
un suggerimento guardare da live di
aiuto pure guarda perché non ammazzare
che li mortacci tua
se l'ultimo che rimane vivo scommetto e
maledetta io lo stato da ammazzo ti
ammazzo ti ammazzo io vi dico chi ha
prima donna ha ucciso nella vasca per
caso
no però la maschera è sempre morto e
campi da basket e non solo se siete male
stai parlando della macchina e pezzo di
merda dove sei ma la macchina era a nord
ove erano sei qua dietro scommetto
oppure non sento ne ha qualcuno vedo
qualcuno lo vedo delitto vediamo cosa
c'è di là dove sei tu
sono alla macchina è sì ok perfetto
[Musica]
a pensa di merda sa cos'è la emi
skidmore cos'è razzisti e non lo è
quando quel tipo resiste no
uno è scappato con la polizia ok quindi
come no eh sì si può evidentemente
scappare dalla polizia solo anno e non
funziona
avete ancora uno scarsone andiamo
convinti minuti che porca di quella in
mano sta merda titanic e non trovo sta
cavolo di banchi ma perché non è la
mappa e no e se no è cioè dai set arriva
dal giro non li hai la mappa sai che non
riesco a capire dove la gente ma solo
uno può scappare con la polizia non ha
secondo me no siete rimasti in due e zio
quindi vi spacco il culo
no non ci provare non ci provare po dove
abiti
ma [ __ ] eccoli act i pluck e cori
con la tanichetta ecco il picco a salve
buongiorno come andiamo alla nascosti
ascolti c'è questo tasto 4 che cos'è
vediamo un po
ma è la haye non facciamo morale che tpa
distaccati lesbica lesbica è lesbica a
lesbica è la madonna
oggi cannavacciuolo insegna e cotolette
di pietra insegnamenti dai di vino 20
dovrebbe fare lo stronzo amati puoi
nascondere nelle tende allora è in mezzo
alla foresta che sta camminando dove è
non lo so lo re è in mezzo alla foresta
c'è un mascara figlio solo questo sia un
traliccio della corrente io ero questo
ok è vicino a un buon fire il campo di
quello del campo sarà la cura provando
no qui alla pura e la cura ma non sono
io non ti vede dove si vede fermo 2
eccoci qua
eccoti che hanno preso tale dato ha dato
tanto e stata data
buongiorno andiamo a posto ti piace
questo gioco è bello sto gioco ai game
oggi insegniamo a fare le cotolette di
persone uccidendo ovvero è saltato che
cos'è che è bello e 5 su 6 e nel male
per la prima volta fatto sono un
[ __ ] però c'è un peccato mica tutti
viano si sono massacrati
ah ah ah terreno da mamma che bello che
mia conclusione di cavani sta troppo nel
tempo a vecchia a lesbica nella foto
allora ti spiego
sai come fosse come essere jason come
c'è un modo per essere jason te lo giuro
guarda filing match l'iva vettel ha
fatto una partenza ci sei tu vai su
settings five games and nothing no
aspetta non equa porca [ __ ] era kustom
ice man 1 menu principale qeusto mais
ok spawn preference e c'è jason o nero
consuelo e poi dismettere o entrambi o
cosi o jason
ma se un altro a jason ovviamente non è
che sei contendente tu e lui però tutti
capito
non sapevo tutta a caraffa voglia sono
forieri di false non è come che riuscivo
c'è sfigata che ci garda va dai ragazzi
e basta basta dire che non hanno fatto
cagare in tutte le partite prima che poi
erano però con jason giocato bene e poi
faccio vedere io ho fatto i culi sice
litografica mentre vanno però agli altri
che ho fatto in cui c'e nessuno cosi
quindi aspetta che apro cosa c'è questa
musichetta di sottofondo e poi c'è
ancora la musica di venerdì 13 è
bruttissimo mi chiami tutto ringrazio il
naso che mi prude ma che sniffa ragazzi
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto come
seguire più successo al momento è un mi
piace sempre bello fare light che non
deve evitare gli dei i b days
né mi piace un sacco parlerai vedendo
raga io spero che vi sia piaciuto il
video spolli chat è per venerdì 13
soprattutto per essere stato jason o
alla fine ne avete detto di farò la fine
vera di triciclo fatto e sull'uscita
essere jason amiche incredibile velocità
fare una cosa bella
daje vi auguro buona per i cantanti raga
mi raccomando iscrivetevi tutti quanti
che entro agosto dobbiamo arrivare a
4 milioni sarà impossibile ma noi ci
proveremo agosto mi chiamo se domani
però vabbè dopo però entro fine agosto
dai dai dai che è impossibile non
succede ma se succede agli scarsi ma ti
ammazzi all'esercito ragazzi cose 200
momento che mi piace anche al comitato
tale iscrizione ma poi si stoppano
dell'hiv non mi ricordo più asciutto
anche i troppi streaming aiuto ce l'ho
già ce ne sono per i siti scrivete henry
ci vediamo alla prossima vita è bella
beh da ragazzi